hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the citrate test the citrate test
which is one of many biochemical tests
that can be used to identify bacteria in
a laboratory setting so the way the
citrate test works is that some bacteria
can use a compound called citrate which
is drawn right here in the absence of
any other source of carbon so that means
that even though there's no glucose no
sucrose and lactose no other source of
carbon for them to use only citrate they
can actually use that as their carbon
source of course carbon is needed to
make things like DNA and RNA and
proteins and lipids and carbohydrates
and so they can use this in the in the
absence of other carbon source whereas
other citrate negative bacteria would
not be able to do so and the reason that
they can use citrate as their only
carbon source is because they produce an
enzyme something like citrate or another
one called citrate permeates to
transport the citrate into the cell
where they can then break it down so in
the citrate test in order to determine
whether or not a specific bacterial
isolate has the ability to transport
citrate inside and break it down and use
it we culture these organisms in the lab
on something called Simmons citrate
auger
and seven citrate agar contains sodium
nitrate again that's what's drawn right
up here also it contains ammonium
dihydrogen phosphate this is an
important source of nitrogen of course
nitrogen is required to make DNA and RNA
those nitrogenous bases there in the
nucleotides and also every amino acid
has a nitrogen in it to me so every
protein has language in it and so that's
why that nitrogen source is important
for the bacteria to be able to grow
there's also some micronutrients and
this auger as well as a pH indicator and
it's this pH indicator that gives us a
color change to tell us whether or not a
specific isolate is citrate positive or
citrate negative and so organisms that
are actually able to utilize this
citrate to transport it in break it down
use it as a carbon source they will as
they grow and replicate they'll also be
breaking down this ammonium zai hydrogen
phosphate and this gives off a basic
product and so by breaking this down a
basic product is given off and remember
we remind ourselves about the pH scale
there are acidic PHS which are one to
less than seven pH seven is neutral
anything above seven is basic so it's
giving off a basic product and this
makes the pH indicator change colors so
it changes color from green to blue
and so a blue color is a positive test
that means that this was broken down and
this was broken down only because these
bacteria can utilize the citrate and
grow so if we look at the method in more
detail the auger is first inoculated
most often by a deep puncture with a
straight wire this just means that you
have a tube the Simmons citrate auger is
in there you take a straight metal wire
sterilize it in a flame pick up a colony
of the isolate that you want to test and
then just jab it down into the auger on
that straight wire pull the straight
wire out and then incubate at 30 to 37
degrees for about 24 to 48 hours after
this amount of time has passed you look
at the tubes a negative result the
Simmons citrate auger will remain green
so there is no color change meaning that
the pH did not change because that
isolate cannot utilize the sodium
citrate for it to get its carbon a
positive result means a color change to
blue and so that's what we would call a
citrate positive organism some examples
sort of clinically relevant examples
that are would give a positive result
include Klebsiella pneumoniae
citrobacter for UDI and several species
of ant Arab actor and salmon on if
you're interested in learning some more
about other biochemical tests I do have
a playlist that includes videos for
tests like the catalase test and the
oxidase test and the coagulase test so
check that out if you're interested and
thanks for watching biology professor